This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. It's hard to overstate the vastness of the Skid Row neighborhood in L.A. It spans roughly 50 blocks, which is about one fifth the entire downtown area of Los Angeles. In some ways, the streets of Skid Row are a bit like other parts of L.A. That's reporter Carla Greene. There are corner stores in street vendors selling everything from jewelry to loose cigarettes. They're old, break townhouses filled with low-income housing. There are parks where grown-ups gather to talk, and children gather to play.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。很难夸大洛杉矶贫民窟（Skid Row）街区的广阔程度。它跨越了大约50个街区，约占洛杉矶整个市中心面积的五分之一。在某些方面，贫民窟的街道和其他洛杉矶地区有点像。那是记者卡拉·格林。街角有商店，街头小贩兜售着从珠宝到散装香烟的各种商品。那里有破旧的联排别墅，里面住着低收入群体。还有公园，大人们聚在那里聊天，孩子们聚在那里玩耍。
But it's also very clear when you've entered Skid Row. For one thing, there's the smell. The streets of Skid Row often stink of urine and other excrement, baking under the hot Los Angeles sun. The gutters are lined with trash. And the sidewalks are mostly, and on some blocks entirely, occupied by people's makeshift homes. A dizzying array of tarps and tents stretch out for blocks and blocks, one structure
但当你进入贫民窟时，一切又变得非常明显。首先是气味。贫民窟的街道经常散发着尿液和其他排泄物的恶臭，在洛杉矶炎热的阳光下烘烤着。排水沟里堆满了垃圾。人行道上大部分地方，在某些街区甚至是全部，都被人们的临时住所占据了。令人眼花缭乱的防水布和帐篷延伸了数个街区，一个接一个的建筑
jutting up against the next and the next. And there are lots of people on the street. Many of them pushing special red shopping carts. The carts are handed out by a local advocacy group because the police used to arrest people for having what they believed were stolen shopping carts. And so all the person got to do is just be homeless and come here, you know, stand me in a register and give you a shopping cart. But homeless and come here, you know, stand me in a register, give you a shopping cart. Right? And people use it to push their property around and stuff like that in. And the cops hate them as well. That's General Dogeon walking around Skid Row with me.
紧挨着另一个。街上有很多人。他们中的许多人推着特制的红色购物车。这些购物车是由当地的一个倡导组织分发的，因为警察过去常以人们持有他们认为是偷来的购物车为由逮捕他们。所以一个人能做的就是无家可归，然后来到这里，你知道，站在登记处，给你一个购物车。但无家可归，来到这里，你知道，站在登记处，给你一个购物车。对吧？人们用它来推他们的财产之类的东西。警察也讨厌这些车。那是正在和我一起在贫民窟走动的杰内尔·多贡。
He's a community organizer and lifelong resident of the neighborhood. He was lived in both low-income housing and on the streets here. So this year, so I'm going to raise on Skid Row. My parents met in the 50s. They both got a job at Bullock's Department store on 7th and Broadway. They went to lunch, fell in love. I was born nine months later in General Hospital. And I've been downtown every since. Walking through Skid Row, it's not hard to see when you reach the edge, the line that divides
他是一位社区组织者，也是该街区的终身居民。他曾住过低收入住房，也曾流落街头。所以今年，我在贫民窟长大。我父母在50年代相识。他们都在第七街和百老汇的布洛克百货公司工作。他们去吃午饭，坠入爱河。九个月后，我在总医院出生。从那以后，我就一直待在市中心。走在贫民窟，不难看出你何时到达了边缘，那条划分
Skid Row from the rest of downtown. And if you stand right there, you'll notice that you're at the intersection of two radically different neighborhoods. So Main Street is a divided line. Main Street is the divided line between the halves and the halves down because you got homeless people that sleep on one side of the street and the loft building's on the other side of the street. And some of the homeless people lay down and they can look up and see the TV in the loft building. So that's a divide-align for your hair. And in Los Angeles, that dividing line between halves and have-nots, between Skid Row and the rest of downtown, it wasn't drawn by accident. It's the result of a very specific plan
贫民窟和市中心其他地方的界线。如果你站在那里，你会注意到你正处于两个截然不同的街区的交汇处。所以主街是一条分界线。主街是富人和穷人之间的分界线，因为街道的一边住着无家可归的人，而另一边是阁楼建筑。一些无家可归的人躺下时，抬头就能看到阁楼建筑里的电视。所以这就是你们的分界线。在洛杉矶，贫民窟和市中心其他地方之间，富人和穷人之间的那条分界线，并非偶然划定。它是经过非常具体的规划
to keep homeless people on one side and development on the other. It's a plan that somewhat surprisingly was written and fought for by advocates of Skid Row's resident population. Back in the early 20th century, the railroad went through downtown Los Angeles right around where Skid Row is now, and like many other cities around the country, a neighborhood formed around the train tracks. So first off, what do we have in front of us here? OK, well, the first thing. Brian Eck is a Los Angeles city planner.
旨在将无家可归者留在这一边，将开发项目留在另一边。令人惊讶的是，这个计划是由贫民窟居民的倡导者撰写并争取来的。早在20世纪初，铁路穿过了洛杉矶市中心，就在现在贫民窟所在的地方，像全国许多其他城市一样，一个街区在铁轨周围形成了。那么首先，我们面前有什么？好的，嗯，第一件事。布莱恩·埃克是一位洛杉矶城市规划师。
It's a, oh, this is beautiful. Yeah, it's a map from 1909. And the reason I've bought this out is this pictorial here of 1909 actually predates zoning. Back when the area now known as Skid Row started to develop, Eck says there weren't any zoning laws in LA to say what types of developments were allowed in different areas. And so what developed at the time, you kind of had the
这是一个，哦，这太美了。是的，这是一张1909年的地图。我把它拿出来的原因是，这张1909年的图画实际上早于分区制。埃克说，在现在被称为贫民窟的地区开始发展时，洛杉矶还没有任何分区法来规定不同地区允许什么样的开发。所以当时发展起来的，你有一种
confluence of the rail and the Los Angeles produce an agricultural market, so at the same point, which brought a large transient population in terms of the railroad workers and our agricultural workers. I've gone through the archives of the LA Times as mentions of Skid Row back a hundred years ago around the turn of the century. Gary Blazzy is a UCLA emeritus professor who is a housing and homeless advocate in and around Skid Row back in the 70s and 80s. So I grew up around the rail yards around downtown and people were referred to in the LA times as, for example, bumps. All the way up into the 70s, most people in Skid Row lived in cheap apartments or single room occupancy hotels or SROs.
铁路和洛杉矶农产品市场的汇合，所以就在同一个点，这带来了大量的流动人口，包括铁路工人和农业工人。我查阅了《洛杉矶时报》的档案，里面提到了100年前世纪之交时的贫民窟。加里·布拉齐是加州大学洛杉矶分校的荣誉教授，他在70年代和80年代是贫民窟内外的住房和无家可归者倡导者。所以我是在市中心的铁路调车场附近长大的，当时人们在《洛杉矶时报》中被称为，例如，流浪汉。一直到70年代，贫民窟的大多数人住在廉价公寓或单间居住酒店（SRO）里。
There were homeless people, but fewer than there are now. When I saw what I was a kid, was homelessness was just to winos. Again, General Dogon, who was living in Skid Row in the seventies. So you had a occasional winos and a majority of them was white males and I managed to drink white pork and all that kind of stuff. Skid Row was not yet the sprawling tent city that it would go on to become, but it was still considered a rough neighborhood where people went to seek out drugs or drink all day and sleep on benches, and the homeless population was growing.
当时有无家可归的人，但比现在少。我小时候看到的，无家可归只是指酒鬼。再次提到杰内尔·多贡，他在七十年代住在贫民窟。所以你偶尔会有酒鬼，他们中的大多数是白人男性，我设法喝白猪肉之类的东西。贫民窟还不是后来那种蔓延的帐篷城市，但它仍然被认为是一个粗糙的街区，人们去那里寻找毒品或整天喝酒，睡在长椅上，无家可归的人口正在增长。
As Skid Row grew, the greater downtown area of LA was also growing and developing, and the developers didn't like what was happening in Skid Row. So, for example, the Union Rescue Mission, It was on Main Street, and there were lots of people there. It was full all the time. There were people lined up outside. A lot of activity there. There was essentially an open-air drug market around the corner of Fifth and Main Street.
随着贫民窟的增长，洛杉矶更大的市中心地区也在增长和发展，开发商不喜欢贫民窟发生的事情。例如，联合救援任务中心，它在主街上，那里有很多人。它一直都是满的。外面排着队的人。那里有很多活动。在第五街和主街的拐角处，基本上是一个露天的毒品市场。
And so, a plan emerged in 1972. A plan drafted by a group of business people and endorsed by many city officials. To move Skid Row's population out and develop the area for newer, more moneyed residents, it was known as the Silver Book Plan, and it was, essentially, to raise Skid Row. Kick everyone out, bulldoze buildings, start fresh. Of course, residents of Skid Row and their advocates didn't like this new plan, and they began thinking about how to fight it.
于是，1972年出现了一个计划。一个由一群商人起草并得到许多城市官员支持的计划。将贫民窟的人口迁出，为更新、更有钱的居民开发该地区，这被称为《银皮书计划》，它基本上是要铲平贫民窟。把每个人都赶走，推倒建筑物，重新开始。当然，贫民窟的居民和他们的倡导者不喜欢这个新计划，他们开始考虑如何对抗它。
One of those people was Charles L. Sesser, a young lawyer at the time, who remembers coming across some research that showed that when you bulldoze a neighborhood like Skid Row, it just means more Skid Row-like neighborhoods pop up elsewhere. Well, I didn't, we weren't quite sure whether it was true or not. Here's L. Sesser admitting that true or not, the theory was useful. But it was a very useful theory for purposes of saying this is a mistake, that that whole idea was a mistake. The theory that Skid Row would just pop up somewhere else if residents were forced to move,
其中一个人是查尔斯·L·塞瑟，当时的一位年轻律师，他记得偶然发现了一些研究，显示当你推倒像贫民窟这样的街区时，这只是意味着更多像贫民窟一样的街区在其他地方涌现。嗯，我没有，我们不太确定这是不是真的。这是L·塞瑟承认，无论真假，这个理论很有用。但对于说这是一个错误，整个想法是一个错误来说，这是一个非常有用的理论。如果居民被迫搬迁，贫民窟就会在其他地方涌现的理论，
scared people who didn't want Skid Row, residents to end up in their neighborhood. Some of these scared people joined the skid row activist's cause, and the activists were happy to have them. We really did come up with this idea that had some scholarly support, but also really, really helped the advocacy. And so armed with their one study, L. Sessor and other activists came up with an idea to replace the silver book plan, which again would bulldoze Skid Row with another one. Here's Jeff D. Trick, who helped write the new plan.
吓坏了那些不希望贫民窟居民最终出现在他们街区的人。其中一些受惊的人加入了贫民窟活动家的事业，活动家们很高兴有他们加入。我们确实提出了这个有一定学术支持的想法，但也确实，真的帮助了倡导工作。于是，凭借他们的那项研究，L·塞瑟和其他活动家想出了一个主意来取代《银皮书计划》，该计划同样会铲平贫民窟，用另一个计划取而代之。这是杰夫·D·特里克，他帮助撰写了新计划。
We developed what's called the blue book plan. Jeff D. Trick and his wife, Catherine Morris, have been long time advocates for the homeless. They run a well-known soup kitchen in Skid Row called the hippie kitchen. The Blue Book Plan was this, to contain the spread of Skid Row. It's basically what's called the containment plan. This new plan will call it the containment plan from here on out, proposed some pretty radical ideas, including getting all the missions and the charities and other homeless services to physically move their offices so they'd
我们制定了所谓的《蓝皮书计划》。杰夫·D·特里克和他的妻子凯瑟琳·莫里斯长期以来一直是无家可归者的倡导者。他们在贫民窟经营着一家著名的救济厨房，叫“嬉皮厨房”。《蓝皮书计划》是这样的：遏制贫民窟的蔓延。这基本上就是所谓的遏制计划。这个新计划，我们从现在开始称之为遏制计划，提出了一些相当激进的想法，包括让所有的任务中心、慈善机构和其他无家可归者服务机构物理搬迁他们的办公室，这样他们就会
be within the newly drawn borders of Skid Row. Again, Gary Blaisey. The deal was all the services that tend to attract homeless people will be concentrated to the east of Spring Street. And in exchange for that, the redevelopment agency will not only not bulldoze all of the SROs, but it will also fund a separate non-profit called the SRO Housing. The SRO Housing Trust would be charged with protecting and maintaining a whole slew of low-income housing in Skid Row.
在贫民窟新划定的边界内。再次提到加里·布莱西。交易是，所有倾向于吸引无家可归者的服务都将集中在春街以东。作为交换，重建局不仅不会铲平所有的SRO，而且还将资助一个名为“SRO住房”的独立非营利组织。SRO住房信托基金将负责保护和维护贫民窟内的一大批低收入住房。
The activists spent several months writing and developing the containment plan, and they worked every angle trying to get the city to take it seriously. So someone knew someone in the city council. That's Catherine Morris, explaining that they got someone to distribute a draft of the plan to everyone on City Council. And so they agreed that while there was a lunch break, that they would bring these in and put them at every place. So the people came back, the council people came back in, sat down, picked up the first thing on their start paging through this.
活动家们花了几个月的时间撰写和制定遏制计划，他们尝试了各种角度，试图让市政府认真对待它。所以有人认识市议会里的某个人。那是凯瑟琳·莫里斯，解释说他们找人把计划草案分发给了市议会的每个人。所以他们同意，在午休时间，他们会把这些带进来，放在每个人的位置上。所以人们回来，议员们回来，坐下，拿起第一件事开始翻阅。
Where did this come from? I don't know or it came from. The containment plan was enough of a compromise that somehow amazingly it won out It wasn't a legally binding agreement, but it went on to define the city's approach to Skid Row for decades And it was a totally unique approach Charles Ellshusser said no one else was doing what they were doing and nobody really seems to have done it since Ellshusser says he's worked on lots of campaigns to save Skid Row-like neighborhoods or housing projects since the 70s, but Skid Row was the only time he's used containment as a strategy.
这是从哪来的？我不知道它是从哪来的。遏制计划是一个足够的妥协，以至于令人惊讶的是它胜出了。这不是一份具有法律约束力的协议，但它后来定义了城市对贫民窟几十年的处理方式。这是一个完全独特的方法。查尔斯·埃尔舒瑟说，没有其他人做他们正在做的事情，而且似乎从那以后也没有人真正做过。埃尔舒瑟说，自70年代以来，他参与了许多拯救类似贫民窟的街区或住房项目的运动，但贫民窟是他唯一一次使用遏制作为策略。
The Containment Plan made various suggestions on how to keep Skid Row types within the new borders of the neighborhood. There's a section of the plan called inducements that reads. With public restroom, benches, and pleasant open spaces within the contained area of Skid Row, the residents might be inclined to confine their activities to the immediate area. That section would serve as a magnet
《遏制计划》提出了各种建议，关于如何将贫民窟类型的人保持在街区的新边界内。计划中有一个名为“诱导”的部分写道：在贫民窟的遏制区域内设置公共厕所、长椅和宜人的开放空间，居民可能会倾向于将他们的活动限制在直接区域内。那部分将作为一个磁铁
to hold undesirable population elements in Skid Row, not against their will, but of their own accord. And the plan talks about a buffer zone, which would create a border between Skid Row and the rest of downtown. Strong edges will act as buffers between Skid Row and the rest of Central City. When the Skid Row resident enters the buffer, the psychological comfort of the familiar Skid Row environment will be lost. He will feel foreign and will not be inclined to travel far from the area of containment.
将不受欢迎的人口元素留在贫民窟，不是违背他们的意愿，而是出于他们自己的意愿。计划还谈到了一个缓冲区，它将在贫民窟和市中心其他地方之间建立一个边界。强有力的边缘将作为贫民窟和中央城市其他部分之间的缓冲区。当贫民窟居民进入缓冲区时，熟悉环境的心理舒适感就会丧失。他会感到陌生，不会倾向于走得离遏制区域太远。
After the containment policy was officially adopted in 1976, the city started to implement it, including many of the meticulous and uncomfortable suggestions of how exactly to contain Skidrose population, like the buffer zone. I don't remember how I know this, but I do remember like the buffer zone. I don't remember how I know this, but I do remember learning it because that some graduate students from USC were hired basically to shadow people living in Skid Row
在1976年遏制政策正式通过后，市政府开始实施它，包括许多关于如何精确遏制贫民窟人口的细致且令人不舒服的建议，比如缓冲区。我不记得我是怎么知道这个的，但我确实记得像缓冲区。我不记得我是怎么知道这个的，但我确实记得学过它，因为南加州大学的一些研究生被雇佣，基本上是为了跟踪住在贫民窟的人
and to keep track on a map of where they went. And so the question was how broad a buffer zone did you need? How far do people wander from Skid Row? And I think the determination was made that you need a buffer of about two blocks. The city also began using unpleasant design, like annoying bright lights on Skid Row's bordering streets,
并在地图上记录他们的去向。所以问题是，你需要多宽的缓冲区？人们从贫民窟走多远？我认为最终的决定是，你需要大约两个街区的缓冲区。市政府还开始使用令人不快的建筑设计，比如在贫民窟边界街道上令人讨厌的明亮灯光，
to keep homeless people from wanting to expand their territory. A mainstream always had the regular fancy lights, the old metal ones that bent down, and that was it. Again, General Dogon. And so when they start building the lofts on Main Street, they came specifically and they put these big ass prison lights. I know they found no prison lights when I see one. Alright, yeah, about this big and they're brown, you can go over there and look at them.
以防止无家可归者想要扩大他们的领地。主街一直有普通的漂亮灯光，那种弯下来的旧金属灯，就是这样。再次提到杰内尔·多贡。所以当他们开始在主街建造阁楼时，他们专门过来，安装了这些巨大的监狱灯。我知道，当我看到监狱灯时，我认得出来。好吧，是的，大约这么大，它们是棕色的，你可以去那边看看它们。
And that was targeting people who like me, who come outside to SRO and smoke cigarettes, hang out front of the building, or just talk." And then there were the more aggressive measures. If you stayed within the borders of Skid Row, Gary Blaisey says, the cops might not bother you. But... Yeah, if you crossed over that border, then if you looked like you might belong on Skid Row, the cops were going to stop you. The containment zone made some practical sense, both for the city and the residents of Skid Row, but it's also an uncomfortable, dehumanizing idea.
那是在针对像我这样的人，他们出来到SRO抽烟，在建筑物前面闲逛，或者只是聊天。然后还有更激进的措施。如果你待在贫民窟的边界内，加里·布莱西说，警察可能不会打扰你。但是……是的，如果你越过了那条边界，那么如果你看起来像是属于贫民窟的人，警察就会拦住你。遏制区对城市和贫民窟的居民都有一定的实际意义，但这也是一个令人不舒服、非人化的想法。
It's a warehouse. Warehouse is what? It's where you store shit, right? And so, yeah, the idea was to push all of the city of Los Angeles, unfavorable citizens, right, in one general area. Elcester, the lawyer who helped write the plan, says, if the way it's written sounds unempathetic or even offensive, that's because they weren't trying to run a PR campaign. They weren't trying to change politician's minds about Skid Row's residents. They were desperately, frantically, trying to save Skid Row
这是一个仓库。仓库是什么？就是你储存垃圾的地方，对吧？所以，是的，这个想法是把洛杉矶市所有不受欢迎的公民，推到一个总的区域。埃尔舒瑟，那位帮助撰写计划的律师说，如果它的书写方式听起来缺乏同情心甚至令人反感，那是因为他们不是在试图进行公关活动。他们不是在试图改变政客对贫民窟居民的想法。他们是在绝望地、疯狂地试图拯救贫民窟
from being paved over. And containment was better than doing nothing. Here's Jeff D. Triggan, who co-authored the plan. You know, it's spoken of rather derisively. Maybe we could have thought of a better name, but it's better than, you know, the... The iteration plan. Yeah, exactly. In case you didn't catch that, he was saying it'd be better than an obliteration plan. For better or worse, over the course of just a few years,
免于被铲平。而且遏制总比什么都不做要好。这是杰夫·D·特里克，他是该计划的共同作者。你知道，人们对此说得相当嘲讽。也许我们可以想出一个更好的名字，但它总比，你知道，那个……抹除计划要好。是的，完全正确。如果你没听清，他是在说这总比抹除计划要好。不管好坏，在短短几年内，
LA's schedule became the place to go if you were homeless in Los Angeles. Some hospitals would even discharge patients there if they didn't have a fixed address. You out out in South Central, you know, or around about, you know, there's very few service providers that give 24 hour assets. There's no place, you know, out in South Central or community where home people can go to and every day get three meals, be able to go take a shower, be able to go to his bathroom, stuff like that.
洛杉矶的贫民窟成了你在洛杉矶无家可归时的去处。有些医院如果病人没有固定地址，甚至会把他们送到那里。你在南中央区，你知道，或者在附近，你知道，很少有服务提供者提供24小时资产。没有地方，你知道，在南中央区或社区，无家可归的人可以去，每天得到三顿饭，能够去洗澡，能够去上厕所，诸如此类。
So all the services is concentrated in one area. So out in South Central, if you homeless, it draws you to scale raw. L.A. was funneling all of its homeless people to scale raw. And in the 1980s, the homeless population of Los Angeles began to explode. Crack was decimating black communities across the city, and many of these newly-addicted people were going to Skid Row. Today, there's a new epidemic. Smokeable cocaine, otherwise known as crack, the super-addictive, and deadly cocaine concentrate. The crack problem has become a crack crisis at its spreading mission-wide. It is an explosively destructive and often lethal substance which is crushing its users.
所以所有的服务都集中在一个区域。所以如果你在南中央区无家可归，它会把你吸引到贫民窟。洛杉矶正在把所有的无家可归者引向贫民窟。在1980年代，洛杉矶的无家可归人口开始爆炸。快克毒品正在摧毁整个城市的黑人社区，许多这些新成瘾的人正在前往贫民窟。今天，有一种新的流行病。可吸食的可卡因，也就是快克，这种超级成瘾且致命的可卡因浓缩物。快克问题已经变成了一场快克危机，它正在全城蔓延。这是一种具有爆炸性破坏力且通常致命的物质，正在摧毁它的使用者。
In the midst of the crack epidemic and the escalating war on drugs, Reagan aggressively cut back the welfare system, which drastically shrank the space between poverty and homelessness. Skidrow wasn't mostly white male alcoholics anymore. For one thing, it became overwhelmingly black. You started seeing families in the streets. People who might have otherwise taken a room in single occupancy hotels just couldn't afford them anymore.
在快克流行和日益升级的禁毒战争中，里根政府积极削减福利制度，这极大地缩小了贫困和无家可归之间的空间。贫民窟不再主要是白人男性酒鬼了。首先，它变得绝大多数是黑人。你开始在街上看到家庭。那些本来可能在单间居住酒店租个房间的人，再也负担不起了。
You can't live two, three days in a motel in LA with $200. So people like what hell are myasos keep my $200 and get a tenth. You know what I mean? Just crash out and save my money to eat on." Gary Blasey was a young advocate at the Legal Aid Foundation at the time. And he remembers that Skid Row was so crowded it felt unsafe. It went from, you would see, you know, a few people in a block, to you would see a hundred people on a block. Meaning that basically people were shoulder to shoulder. And so the density was just, I mean, it was like,
你不能在洛杉矶用200美元在汽车旅馆住两三天。所以像我这样的人，我的200美元留着买个帐篷。你知道我的意思吗？只是崩溃，省下钱来吃饭。”加里·布莱西当时是法律援助基金会的年轻倡导者。他记得贫民窟太拥挤了，感觉不安全。它从你会在一个街区看到几个人，变成你会在一个街区看到一百个人。意味着基本上人们是肩并肩的。所以密度简直是，我的意思是，它就像，
it was a completely insane place. Blazzy remembers that for Christmas of 1984, in an effort to get folks from shelter, he and some other advocates set up two big tents with a bunch of cats on an empty patch of land at just opposite city hall. And pretty soon there were 800 people sleeping on cats on those tents. In the last couple of decades conditions on Skid Row have changed a bit.
一个完全疯狂的地方。布莱西记得1984年的圣诞节，为了让人们住进避难所，他和一些其他倡导者在市政厅对面的一块空地上搭了两个大帐篷，里面放了一堆小床。很快就有800人睡在那些帐篷里的小床上。在过去的几十年里，贫民窟的情况发生了一些变化。
There are fewer homeless people. They are no longer sleeping shoulder to shoulder on the street. But Skid Row has endured as a place for homeless people to live and find services. Even as other Skid Row-style neighborhoods around the country were eaten up by gentrification and their residents were scattered around their respective cities. And over the years, the sense of community in Skid Row has only gotten stronger.
无家可归的人少了。他们不再在街上肩并肩地睡觉。但贫民窟作为无家可归者居住和寻找服务的地方一直存在。即使全国其他类似贫民窟的街区被绅士化吞噬，居民被分散到各自的城市。多年来，贫民窟的社区意识反而变得更强了。
The neighborhoods become not just a hub for social services, but for activism around poverty and homelessness. And we always seen it as community, right? I get more, hey, how you doing, brother, what's up? Hey, how you doing, General Doga? When I walk on this, and get broke, then I do it when I walk on the, the Yuppa Fires side. They walk past you like they don't even see you. Some of them are a lot of them I know.
这个街区不仅成为了社会服务的中心，也成为了围绕贫困和无家可归进行激进主义的中心。我们一直把它看作社区，对吧？当我走在上面时，我得到更多的是“嘿，你好吗，兄弟，怎么了？嘿，你好吗，杰内尔·多贡？”然后我走在雅皮士那一侧时，他们走过你身边，好像根本没看见你。他们中的一些人，我认识很多。
And they still don't wait. We don't have no animosity or nothing. This is a community down here. We work to make this a community. Apart from the containment plan, there's another major reason why Skid Row has not been taken over by new apartment buildings. And that's zoning. Aside from the single-room occupancy hotels and a bit of other low-income housing that was grandfathered in, most of Skid Row is zoned industrial, rather than commercial or residential.
他们仍然不理会。我们没有任何敌意或什么。这是一个社区。我们努力使这里成为一个社区。除了遏制计划，贫民窟没有被新公寓大楼接管的另一个主要原因是分区。除了单间居住酒店和一些其他被祖父条款保护的低收入住房外，贫民窟的大部分地区被划为工业区，而不是商业或住宅区。
Again, city planner Brian Eck. In the eastern half of Skid Row where it is zoned industrial, that has precluded the expansion or the ability to create new housing there. But all of that could soon change. Los Angeles is currently undertaking a total re-haul of its zoning code, starting with downtown, and a lot of Skid Row that was formally zoned industrial will probably be re-zoned as mixed use. There are a lot of vacant buildings in Skid Row, and the city would like to make some of that
再次提到城市规划师布莱恩·埃克。在贫民窟的东半部，那里被划为工业区，这排除了在那里扩张或创造新住房的能力。但这一切很快就会改变。洛杉矶目前正在对其分区法规进行全面彻底的改革，从市中心开始，贫民窟中许多以前被划为工业区的地区可能会被重新划为混合用途。贫民窟有很多空置建筑，市政府希望利用其中一些
real estate available for housing. Many residents of Skid Row would love to have new housing. They've been asking for it for years. Having more housing has been something that they have expressed as something that's critical for the neighborhood, having grocery stores with healthy and accessible and cheap food. The city is basically saying in order to give you housing, we have to rezone. But Skid Row residents want new housing in their neighborhood to be affordable, and that isn't something that can be dealt with through zoning. Zoning can say whether an area is industrial or residential or mixed, but it can't say if housing will be affordable.
房地产用于住房。许多贫民窟的居民很乐意有新的住房。他们多年来一直要求这样做。拥有更多的住房是他们表达的对街区至关重要的事情，拥有提供健康、可及且廉价食品的杂货店。市政府基本上是在说，为了给你住房，我们必须重新分区。但贫民窟的居民希望他们街区的新住房是可负担的，而这不能通过分区来解决。分区可以说明一个地区是工业区、住宅区还是混合区，但它不能说明住房是否可负担。
That would have to be done legislatively. Some skid row residents believe political leaders could find a way to build affordable housing in the neighborhood, but instead they'll use the rezoning process as an excuse to open up the real estate market and get them out. Like Craig R, he don't want to give me his last name, but he's a longtime resident of Skid Row. And he says zoning is just a tool. The tool they want to use to get rid of the homeless people and create this new
那必须通过立法来完成。一些贫民窟的居民认为政治领导人可以找到在街区建造可负担住房的方法，但相反，他们会利用重新分区过程作为借口来开放房地产市场并将他们赶走。像克雷格·R，他不想告诉我他的姓，但他是一位长期的贫民窟居民。他说分区只是一个工具。他们想用来摆脱无家可归者并创造这个新的
gentrification program is zoning. They're planning on making billions of dollars by pushing us out, squeezing us out, or kicking us out, meaning us to pour people to disadvantaged people, the homeless and plus the residents of the neighborhood. Even without zoning changes, Skid Row is getting smaller. Containment was never a legally binding agreement, and the city seems to be increasingly less guided by it. There's a whole neighborhood, actually, that juts up against Skid Row. That used to essentially be a part of it. It's a new hip neighborhood filled with art galleries and sheet cafes.
绅士化计划的工具就是分区。他们计划通过把我们推出去、挤出去或踢出去来赚取数十亿美元，这意味着把我们这些穷人、弱势群体、无家可归者以及街区的居民赶走。即使没有分区变化，贫民窟也在变小。遏制从来不是一份具有法律约束力的协议，市政府似乎越来越少受其指导。实际上，有一个完整的街区紧挨着贫民窟。它曾经基本上是它的一部分。这是一个新的时髦街区，到处是艺术画廊和别致的咖啡馆。
It's called the Arts District. And as the areas around Skid Row have continued to gentrify, taking bites out of the edges of the neighborhood, Skid Row itself has changed, including General Dogan says, the police presence. In 2006, the city launched what they called a safer citizen industry, which brought 110 extra police to Skid Row, so that containment zones being broken up, busted up by the police. The police come in, swinging clubs, people sprang out. And so that's why you got to 10, so all by the freeway,
它被称为艺术区。随着贫民窟周围的地区继续绅士化，蚕食着街区的边缘，贫民窟本身也发生了变化，包括杰内尔·多贡所说的警察的存在。2006年，市政府发起了他们所谓的“更安全城市倡议”，这给贫民窟带来了110名额外的警察，所以那个遏制区正在被警察打破、捣毁。警察进来，挥舞着警棍，人们四散奔逃。这就是为什么你会在高速公路边看到帐篷，
all over here. Because people say, you know what's happening? I'd rather be over here on 43rd Street in my 10th. You know what's going to be able to chill out. You know what's going to be then being on San Julian Street against the wall being jacked up three or four times a day. Back in 1976, when Elsa, Susser and Morris and other activists came up with the containment plan, they included a map that laid out exactly what the borderers of Skid Row would be.
到处都是。因为人们说，你知道发生了什么吗？我宁愿在第43街的帐篷里。你知道那会很放松。你知道那会比在圣朱利安街靠着墙，一天被搜身三四次要好。早在1976年，当埃尔舒瑟、莫里斯和其他活动家提出遏制计划时，他们包括了一张地图，详细列出了贫民窟的边界。
They were trying to make a deal, a kind of compromise. Will stay over here. Just don't try to push us out with new development, and we'll stay contained. Everybody assigned up for housing is still on the street. That's right! Not here! Just a couple weeks ago, Skid Row residents and activists were out on the street fighting for those same borders, the ones from the 1976 containment plan, but with a different attitude. They're not trying to contain Skid Row. They're trying to contain development,
他们试图达成一项交易，一种妥协。我们会待在这里。只要别试图通过新的开发项目把我们赶走，我们就会保持被遏制。每个人都签了名要求住房，但仍然在街上。没错！不是这里！就在几周前，贫民窟的居民和活动家走上街头，为同样的边界而战，那些1976年遏制计划中的边界，但态度不同。他们不是在试图遏制贫民窟。他们是在试图遏制开发，
or at least the luxury housing development that's currently being considered right at the edge of Skid Row. It's a 33-story high-rise apartment building, just needs approval from the local councilmen to move forward. There are about two dozen people at the protest, including General Dogon.
或者至少是目前正在贫民窟边缘考虑的豪华住房开发项目。这是一栋33层的高层公寓大楼，只需要当地议员的批准就可以推进。抗议活动中有大约两打人，包括杰内尔·多贡。
This is ours. Don't build here, they're saying. Or else? We'll be back! We'll be back! We'll be back! We'll be back! We'll be back! LA's Skid Row was not the first Skid Row. Avery Troll from it has a story of what is rumored to be the first use of the phrase. After this. So I'm in the studio with Avery Troll from it, and coincidentally, you were doing a story in Seattle where you ended up on another Skid Row.
这是我们的。别在这里盖楼，他们说。否则呢？我们会回来的！我们会回来的！我们会回来的！我们会回来的！我们会回来的！洛杉矶的贫民窟并不是第一个贫民窟。艾弗里·特鲁夫曼有一个关于据说是该短语首次使用的故事。之后再说。所以我和艾弗里·特鲁夫曼在演播室里，巧合的是，你当时正在西雅图做一个故事，最后你到了另一个贫民窟。
And not just any Skid Row. It was maybe where the name skid row comes from. So if you go to Seattle and you go downtown, you will encounter a place called Pioneer Square, which is actually a triangle. And it is the tourist area. And Seattle used to be a really big logging town. And the mill used to be right downtown. So loggers would go up into the hills and chop down these massive, huge trees, and they lubricate them with fish oil and hook the logs up to teams of oxen and mules. And then would run the logs down this road over the mill.
而且不仅仅是任何贫民窟。它可能是贫民窟这个名字的来源。所以如果你去西雅图，去市中心，你会遇到一个叫先锋广场的地方，它实际上是一个三角形。它是旅游区。西雅图曾经是一个非常大的伐木城镇。磨坊曾经就在市中心。所以伐木工会去山上砍伐这些巨大的树木，他们用鱼油润滑它们，把原木钩在牛和骡子的队伍上。然后会把原木沿着这条路拖到磨坊。
Now that would be called dragging or skidding the logs. Skidding the logs makes this road the skid road. It was called skid road with a D according to my guide, Dean N'Jarian, and that street is now called Yesler Way because Henry Yesler was the owner of the mill at the end of the street where the logs were being skidded down to, and this mill was also very close to the seaport. And so here in this part of town,
现在这被称为拖拽或滑行原木。滑行原木使这条路成为滑行路（Skid Road）。根据我的向导迪恩·恩贾里安的说法，它被称为带D的Skid Road，那条街现在叫耶斯勒路，因为亨利·耶斯勒是街道尽头磨坊的主人，原木被滑行到那里，这个磨坊也离海港很近。所以在这个城镇的这一部分，
you've got these sailors who are taking their shoreleave and then these loggers, there are like a lot of guys around and they've got these hard jobs with long periods of downtime. They are looking for action and fun, luckily. Seattle in this area and the Skid Row was here to provide. Before there was Vegas, Sin City was right here. A lot of bars, a lot of brothels. So this is the original Skid Row. Maybe, maybe? before there was Vegas, Sin City was right here. A lot of bars, a lot of brothels.
你有这些休假的船员，还有这些伐木工，周围有很多男人，他们有这些艰苦的工作，有很长的停工期。他们正在寻找刺激和乐趣，幸运的是。西雅图在这个地区，贫民窟就在这里提供服务。在拉斯维加斯出现之前，罪恶之城就在这里。很多酒吧，很多妓院。所以这是最初的贫民窟。也许，也许？在拉斯维加斯出现之前，罪恶之城就在这里。很多酒吧，很多妓院。
So this is the original Skid Row. Maybe, maybe. There were other towns, I have to confess, there are other towns that had Skid Roads as a functional term of the logging industry and other parts of the world. I don't know if those other Skid Roads also developed like bars and red light districts
所以这是最初的贫民窟。也许，也许。还有其他城镇，我必须承认，还有其他城镇有作为伐木业功能术语的滑行路，以及世界其他地方。我不知道那些其他的滑行路是否也发展成了酒吧和红灯区
and rough attitudes, but that's definitely what happened in Seattle. More about that in a future story. Cool. Thanks for stopping in. Yeah, thank you. 99% of Isabel was produced this week by Carla Green, Mix and Tech production by Sharif Usif, Music by Sean Riel.
和粗暴的态度，但这绝对是西雅图发生的事情。未来会有更多关于这个的故事。酷。谢谢你过来。是的，谢谢你。《99%隐形》本周由卡拉·格林制作，混音和技术制作由谢里夫·尤西夫完成，音乐由肖恩·里尔创作。
Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kurt Colstead is the digital director, Avery Truffman played the voice. The rest of the team is Emmett Fitzgerald Delaney Hall, Teran Mazza, and me, Roman Mars. Special thanks to John Mel Pied and Henriette Browers of the Los Angeles Poverty Department. They have a number of really interesting exhibitions on Skid Row's history and present
凯蒂·明格尔是我们的高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监，艾弗里·特鲁夫曼担任配音。团队的其他成员是埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、德莱尼·霍尔、特兰·马扎，还有我，罗曼·马尔斯。特别感谢洛杉矶贫困部门的约翰·梅尔·皮德和亨丽埃特·布劳尔斯。他们有许多关于贫民窟历史和现状的非常有趣的展览
at their space in downtown Los Angeles. Thanks also to Linus Shentu and everyone at the Los Angeles Community Action Network. We are a project of 91.7K ALW San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% of visible is part of radio-topia from PRX a collective of the best, most innovative, best-looking shows and all
在他们位于洛杉矶市中心的空间里。也感谢莱纳斯·申图和洛杉矶社区行动网络的所有人。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心的广播街制作。《99%隐形》是PRX广播托邦的一部分，这是一个由播客界最优秀、最具创新性、最美观的节目组成的集体。
of podcasting. We are supported by the Night Foundation and Coin Carrying Donors, just like you. You can find this show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But our true home on the web is 99PI.org. Radio TMP from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们得到了奈特基金会和像你一样的硬币捐赠者的支持。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并加入关于节目的讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg。我们在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上也有账号。但我们在网络上真正的家是99PI.org。来自PRX的广播托邦。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。